zack we are back and we are announcing
something big and exciting
the arrival of lobby three we've been on
the grind we have been yeah you're
always kind of on a grind but i've been
we've been doing some behind the scenes
grinding on this working on and so
people who've worked with me for a while
know that sometimes when i'm doing
something i'm excited i'm just like hey
we're doing this yes um in this case
we've been working on it for
a number of weeks and months and haven't
talked about it openly until now so what
the heck is lobby three
lobby three
is
our effort to help explain web3
technologies and their potential to
combat poverty
to
the folks in dc the regulators the
lawmakers to make sure that they don't
do something
that uh
stifles this innovation before it can
even really
uh get going or reach its full potential
um super pumped about it and i want to
retrace my steps through
uh the last number of years we're
getting into crypto
we're entering the metaverse
is anyone surprised
no if the headline is andrean gets into
web three
i i've sort of had one foot in one foot
out for a while though as a political
figure i didn't go too far in because
uh you know um it was going to be over
the heads of a lot of voters and like
there are a bunch of other things
but my first major interaction with this
community was speaking at conferences
and events when i was running for
president consensus was one of the first
ones right yes something around there
there was a blockchain for good
conference i attended in san francisco
and meeting
these people
uh first it was like these are these are
my people it's like my truck they were
your people yeah yeah it was very
optimistic
entrepreneurial
like
and nine out of ten of them were for
some version of ubi
yeah as well and i would say the vast
majority were like yang gang or yang
gang adjacent although the vast majority
probably didn't vote no offense
we love you
uh
if you had voted we might have been a
different you might be having this
conversation at gracie mansion well
there might not have been that many in
yeah but so my interactions with the
community were always very energizing
and invigorating it became evident that
if you're trying to combat poverty this
is maybe the single greatest opportunity
that exists today
because you've had hundreds of billions
of dollars worth of value
and thousands and thousands of jobs
generated over the last number of months
really
surprising just about anyone
if you were to rewind the clock gosh not
even that many years right you know five
years yep i'd say so a couple things a
lot of folks
so i found that people either turned on
by crypto or been or have been turned
off right where you're like this is the
greatest thing in the world and they're
down a rabbit hole and they're starting
nft projects and all that stuff or
they're like screw this it's a bubble i
don't understand well here's what you
think yeah so a lot of people interact
with it in a very superficial way
the potential of the blockchain has been
clear for a while where imagine you have
this is a technical term but they talk
about as a distributed ledger
but let's imagine that you had a slew of
interactions
that no one can affect or alter so that
you can trust everything and that if
anyone does make any kind of move then
it's evident for all to see correct so
if you had that kind of system you could
vote securely you could have a
completely different broadly accessible
financial system
you could have a truly distributed
internet that's not controlled by a few
mega corps you would take out a lot of
middlemen
you could get rid of a lot of accounts
and lawyers a lot of leeches because
there are a lot of major professional
services firms that their uh primary
value is papering up a transaction that
if you could document it on the
blockchain then problem solved i
actually remember this so i was a an
unhappy corporate attorney for five
months you were in investment banking
so management now i remember there was a
big
acquisition that
we were papering up and at the end of
the acquisition
a partner at the law firm had to sign
something saying hey this is
uh this is legally acceptable and that
partner joked with me that that converse
that signature was worth a million bucks
because really it was this very high-end
law firm putting its name on the fact
that
this is kosher this is legal
everything's gonna be fine like that
that
firm placing its
brand and reputation behind the legality
of the transaction
was what was being paid for in many ways
yes so you end up not needing any of
that because you could see for yourself
that this is legit
yes
so when you talk about the potential of
this technology it is vast and has been
for quite some time yes now in terms of
the
applications and implementations to date
have we reached that level no nowhere
near it nowhere near nowhere near it
that's what's exciting and so what
you're seeing now is a bunch of
applications that people can look at and
say
well
you know i'm
unsure whether
this
uh is going to be what's built on this
technology long term
it's like a lot of other new
technologies where they're going to be a
slew of applications and implementations
think even for those who remember this
stuff when the internet first came out
there were like a ton of different
websites
and then when the bubble
popped a lot of those websites went away
but you had some game-changing companies
uh like amazon and paypal and others
that you know stood the test of time
correct um now there's already been a
couple of boom bust cycles um in crypto
but there are going to be some
game-changing companies that come out of
this 100
yes and it will be
this isn't going away that's like that
what i'd say is this is you and i
we were running for president when like
the early adopters were really getting
in right you could still say it's the
early adoption phase a bit but they had
super bowl commercials not that early
anymore um
but when we were running a lot of folks
were getting into this and we're like
this is cool
not sure what it is that sort of thing
and then we've been spending
the last
definitely last four months
like hard like very intently in this
space um intensely in this space but
probably last six to eight months like
really
um exploring it like at least casually
and talking to leaders in it and trying
to figure out okay what are the problems
what are the needs yes and the single
biggest problem that we heard over and
over again was hey we're concerned that
the legislators and regulators don't get
us washington dc is going to mess us up
yeah i mean there was some language in
the infrastructure bill that defined
broker deal in a way that encompassed
essentially everyone under the sun it
made no sense uh and if that were
implemented then it would really
uh
offshore a lot of this industry which is
exactly the opposite of what you want
right um so we heard over and over again
uh that the stories aren't being told
the
use cases aren't being explained
properly uh there's a caricature of both
the people in the industry and what it's
being used for so the caricature is uh
hey this is all being used for illicit
drug deals uh and human trafficking and
the people that are rich kid that looks
like me to sell his monkey and the
people that are using it are
uh either bad actors or tech bros uh or
um people
who haven't
you know had any needs um meanwhile in
reality when you start interacting with
folks who are part of this community
there are a lot of artists who are being
compensated for their creations in a way
that was completely not possible before
and by the way it has changed their
lives from
you know
living hand to mouth or even in some
cases living in their car i mean you've
got extreme cases where people were yeah
homeless to
like either millionaires but you have a
lot of artists they're like i'm able to
fund my lifestyle now yeah um that's
like the more
average case than the extreme ones that
we hear about sometimes yeah and so
there were a number of things that
really were hand in hand with
uh the presidential campaign where one
of the reasons why we were so pro
universal basic income is that it could
give rise to a creative economy and
that's what's happened
uh with web3 in many cases
we also wanted to find a way to monetize
different types of positive social
actions
because and this is linked even to the
conversation we've been having around
men and boys and jobs and a bunch of
other things where if you had a system
of
uh tokens and rewards and incentives for
me volunteering in my community helping
my neighbor
grandma taking care of grandma working
out like doing something positive for my
mental health like you know what
whatever it is um then you can create uh
a new
network and also a set of structures
that help give
people men in particular
a degree of reinforcement and
purpose and fulfillment and so this is
something that i actually this is funny
on the presidential um so it's in my
book and a lot of you read my book the
war on normal people and i called it
digital social credits
and by the way zach is laughing because
early in the campaign he was like you're
not allowed to talk about digital social
credits ever again
um because the asian guy talking about
digital social credits just seems like
you know
frankly china social engineering and
like blah blah blah you were also
already far out you know what i'm saying
you already the free money guy or ubi
you had a bunch of new ideas and then
this one was like so far out and i we
understood why you did it like if you
ever talk to you but it was just another
thing you had to explain yeah so clearly
the idea of digital social credits and
tokens it's already happening yes now
uh in the metaverse with web3 and crypto
so uh so there were a bunch of things
that were super aligned about the vision
and when the leaders in this community
were to identify a need some of them
would say you know what uh andrew you'd
actually be really good fit to help make
this case because you were like a
political actor who has relationships on
both sides of the aisle and a public
profile and what many of them did not
know but now they do know is that uh we
had started an advocacy organization in
dc that had been doing this sort of work
around anti-poverty measures like cash
relief and
enhanced child tax credit
and so it really is a perfect fit
because
this can be the next big step in
fighting poverty if and if we're able to
demonstrate what these technologies can
do to enable for example like a
poor
neighborhood in ohio or washington dc to
get access to financial services in a
way that they couldn't before and by the
way not just access but i have some
buying power right
[Music]
you